- I'm about to uber-fact-check
these UberFacts.
Are you a motion graphics designer
that has really top-notch editing skills?
There's a link down
below for you to apply.
Do it, do it.
Let's just get started. Pee-woop!
"After kissing someone passionately,
their DNA can linger in your
mouth for more than an hour."
I don't know why through that
passionately thing in there,
but this is true.
Not only are you sharing the bacteria,
fungi, viruses, all of them microbiota
that exist inside your mouth,
you're also sharing some of your DNA.
It's also called saliva swapping.
(lips smooching)
"Bonding with dogs causes
your brain to release dopamine
and oxytocin in the same
way as loving a child."
Bear, you're like my child.
It's also the same thing that's released
when you're cuddling with someone.
Oxytocin is also known
as the cuddle hormone,
but you also let off something
known as beta-endorphin,
which also is a feel-good,
positively attributed neurotransmitter
that your body just makes you feel loved.
"The human mouth is dirtier
than a toilet seat."
Ah, this, I mean, it depends
on your definition of dirty.
Because if you're doing
strictly bacteria, it is true.
If you ever actually hit
someone in the face with a punch
and their tooth goes into your knuckle,
that could be a fight bite
so that when the bacteria
gets into the joint
or near the joint,
or when you reposition
your hand like that,
it can no longer escape, gets trapped,
puts you at risk for
osteomyelitis, a bone infection,
septic arthritis, a joint infection,
and those are quite serious,
so we give antibiotics really
quickly for fight bites.
A human sneeze can travel
about 100 miles per hour.
Yeah, this is true.
We've seen on slow motion cameras
where the sneeze microdroplets,
the ones that probably aren't
carrying viral material,
are shooting as far as 27 feet away.
The reason we say stay six feet away
for the influenza and
COVID-19 is because we've seen
that the majority of the heavy droplets
that carry the virus actually
fall at that six-feet rate,
but it doesn't make you
100% protected by any means.
Why did that lady just sneeze on her cat?
"The largest bone in the
human body, the femur,
can support 30 times the
weight of a person's body."
This is, in fact, true.
Strongest bone in the body.
Oh, hey, Bear.
Also, the reality is
to fracture the femur,
it needs to be a high speed
car accident, a very high fall.
You're not gonna just fracture your femur
as a young healthy adult
by walking on the street
and taking a slip.
"If human DNA were uncoiled,
it would stretch 10 billion miles."
- $1 million.
- 10 million, million miles.
That's equivalent going to Pluto and back.
I gotta fact-check that
because that is excessive.
(ambient music)
This fact is actually not true.
Each cell in your body has DNA.
If we uncoiled it, it
would go about six feet.
And then if you add up
all the cells in our body,
that adds up to 67 billion miles,
which is 150,000 round
trips from here to the moon.
I don't know about you
but I've never taken a
round trip to the moon.
If I would, I wouldn't
do it 150,000 times.
"The highest blood alcohol concentration
ever recorded was 0.91%,
more than twice the usual lethal level
and 11 times more than a
legally intoxicated person."
It is potentially 11 times more
than a legally intoxicated person,
but let's see what the
highest recorded on record is.
I'm sure I can find that out.
(ambient music)
All right, this one's false.
There are much higher reported levels
across the globe on this.
The important fact here is actually,
anything above a 0.5 blood alcohol content
is respiratory failure,
death, coma, et cetera.
"When doctors say they
need something stat,
it is a shortened version
of the Latin word statim,
meaning immediately."
Instantly, immediately, yes, this is true.
And that's why we say,
"Chest compressions,
chest compressions,
chest compressions stat,"
because they done immediately
when someone's unconscious
without a pulse.
The Pentagon spends an
estimated 41,600,000
a year on Viagra.
We fact-checked this.
It is absolutely true.
And if you combine it with
drugs like Cialis, Levitra,
which have the same mechanism of action,
that totals $294 million.
The reality is, sometimes we
prescribe these medications
for pulmonary hypertension
in order to lower the
pressure in the lungs.
Some of the other ones are
also used for prostate issues,
so don't judge and think
that it's all about fun.
And sometimes it's about procreation.
"If a male pees on a pregnancy test
and the results are positive,
it could be indicative of cancer."
I like that they put
the word, "It could be,"
because there are certain tumors,
specifically testicular tumors,
that produce this hormone beta-hCG,
which is what we test for when we give you
one of these over-the-counter
pregnancy tests.
So while it's not something I would use
as a screening method for cancer,
if it does show up positive,
that's a good reason
to go see your doctor.
"British researchers have found
that one smile can generate the same level
of brain stimulation as up
to 2,000 bars of chocolate.
That is a lot of chocolate.
Facet-check time.
(gentle music)
It is true,
and it can give you the
same neurological boost
as receiving $25,000.
So smile away.
"Flow is the mental
state your brain enters
when you're completely
involved in an activity
that brings you so much joy,
you lose the sense of space and time."
True.
When you go, let's say, rock climbing,
or you're playing the piano for fun,
there is no financial benefit,
sexual benefit, work benefit,
and yet, we put so much effort
into doing this, burning calories.
It doesn't help our survival
one bit, yet we do it.
Why? Flow.
That's why when you set little goals
for yourself throughout the
day, that brings you joy.
And they're attainable goals,
and we create friendships along the way,
this is the secret to fulfillment.
I don't wanna say happiness.
I'm gonna say fulfillment.
"Humans have the same number
of hairs as chimpanzees,
but our hair is useless
and often invisible."
I mean, if you're talking
about peach fuzz, maybe,
but the reality is, through evolution,
we actually end up losing
the majority of this hair.
For me, what's interesting
is the hair that has remained
and the reasons why it has remained.
For example, think about the eyebrows.
Why do we have eyebrows?
It's really as a way to serve
as a non-verbal communication
representing threat or hostility.
"Exercise reorganizes the brain
so that it is more resistant to stress."
I don't know if reorganize
is the exact term,
but, yes, this does happen.
In fact, the brain has a factor in it
called brain-derived neurotrophic factor,
which actually nourishes
and matures new nerve cells to form.
And as a result, you become
more cognitively capable,
more likely to be comfortable
dealing with stress,
even oxidative stress to some degree.
Some level of activity is
almost always beneficial
to the human mind and body.
"The average person falls
asleep in 10 to 20 minutes."
I know for the people who
are insomniacs out there,
they're gonna get frustrated by this.
This is somewhat true.
My general rule is if
you're rolling around in bed
for more than 20 minutes
and you can't fall asleep,
you probably should get up
and try and do something else
that's calming in order to
help you get sleepy again,
and then come back into bed and try again.
'Cause once you lay there for 20 minutes,
you start developing
anxiety and frustration
with being in the bed not falling asleep.
It's actually conditioning you
to be more anxious the
next time you go to bed.
As opposed to leaving the bed,
being anxious somewhere
else, calming yourself down,
and then going into bed
when you're already tired,
that's the optimal approach.
"For caffeine addicts,
coffee doesn't actually increase alertness
above baseline levels.
It just reverses the fatiguing effects
of acute caffeine withdrawal."
There was a study done on this
that actually did confirm it;
however, it's imperfect study.
I think that, yes, if you
need that temporary boost,
especially early in the morning,
it's totally fine to have a cup of Joe.
However, do not have it after lunch
because caffeine takes several hours,
more than six hours to
clear out of your body.
So if you're taking it at 4 or 5 o'clock,
when you go into bed,
you're gonna to still have
some caffeine in your system,
making it difficult
for you to fall asleep.
Or if you're one of
these addicts that says,
"Oh, I can drink caffeine
and fall asleep like a baby."
Yeah, you can. But guess what?
You're not gonna go through
all the stages of sleep well,
and you're gonna wake
up feeling unrefreshed.
Boom!
(explosive booms)
"It's possible to die from a broken heart.
This condition is called
stress cardiomyopathy."
Actually it's called Takotsobus,
no, Takotsubo cardiomyopathy.
Usually, this causes a
non-ischemic heart attack,
meaning it's not because
of a blocked blood vessel
and your heart ends up
suffering from a lack of oxygen.
90% of the reported cases
are in women ages 58 to 75.
"A sunburn is the result
of your skin cells killing themselves
to protect you from their damaged DNA,
which can cause cancer."
Yeah, this is somewhat true
because they're experiencing what's known
as a type I programmed cell death.
When you have radiation
injury, your body understands
that there could be
genetic mutations there,
so it goes through this
programmed cell death,
creating an inflammatory response.
It's very painful, there's peeling,
the skin cells actually flake off.
This is a protective
mechanism of your body.
"Meditation is such a powerful technique
that after only eight weeks,
the brain structure changes."
I don't know where they
got this eight weeks from.
Couldn't find that
anywhere in the research,
but the reality is,
meditation does change your
brain's electrical activity.
The way we should think of mindfulness
and meditation is just
like any other exercise.
That's why the more you do
it, the better you get at it.
Our brains tend to be anxious beings
that constantly are
going all over the place.
And when you try and control it
for a short period of time of mindfulness,
that takes effort, it's hard.
That's why you should do it
for a short period of time
and then work your way up
to longer periods of time.
And when you do that,
your brain structure is somewhat changing.
So, yeah, meditation all the way.
"Listening to music while exercising
can measurably improve
your physical performance."
Yes, not only can listening music affect
your physical performance,
it could also affect your brainwaves.
It's changes in music,
and also silence can have the same effect.
Music that has like a crescendo
where it's a drop or a climax in it,
will affect the way
your brain is reacting.
It's really, really cool.
"Sweat is actually odorless.
The smell is caused by bacteria
that live on the skin."
I wanna say true 'cause
when people smell BO,
they're really smelling bacteria fart,
so it's true on that end.
However, however, however,
there are pheromones
that sometimes have their own unique scent
that is released when you stress sweat.
And by the way, when you smell something,
that's just the chemical
receptor in your nose.
It's not even a scent receptor,
it just senses chemicals.
How cool is that?
SpongeBob also spreads misinformation.
Click here to check that out.
And as always, stay happy and healthy,
UberFact or not.
(Mike clicks tongue)
(upbeat music)